d'ici 2024 500 nouveaux logements
devraient être sortis de terre débuté en
août 2020 le chantier de la zac de la
remise se poursuit à voisins le
bretonneux
ce futur éco quartier situé en plein
coeur de la ville s'étendra sur 10 à 12
hectares c'est un quartier qui va
répondre aux besoins de notre commune
avec une typologie de logement assez
variés on aura aussi bien du logement
social de l'accession aidée de
l'accession libre du logement locatif
intermédiaire
donc on va voir tous les types de
produits qui peuvent exister une crèche
de 55 berceau en relais d'assistants
maternels un pôle de glisse ou encore
une salle de quartier seront également
créés tout cela avec un objectif le
respect de l'environnement
pour ce faire la rigole qui alimentait
en eau le château de versailles va être
remise en service
on a fait en sorte via le trait sur les
roses sur les voiries à rénover toute la
partie rigole les rigoles anciennes donc
on va récupérer toutes les eaux de pluie
tout le pluvial qui vont sur les
différents lots pour aller récupérer via
un système de nous ça va alimenter les
rigoles quand remet en eau et où le
déversement de ces rigolos lorsque sont
trop remplir en direct dans le bassin de
la sourde oreille un peu plus loin ça
limitera les effets inondations et sa
part en plus de remettre en place à ces
scènes de rigoles anciens ce qu'ils
gagnent tout à fait intéressant des
arbres seront également plantés sur un
hectare
autre particularité une église de 800
places va être construite par la
paroisse de montigny voisin coût global
de l'écoquartier 33 millions d'euros